- There are those officials,
elected and appointed, in some instances
who would have to make decisions
that may run contrary to
their special interests,
but are in the interest
of their constituents.
These are human beings,
who love this country and who
in the time of decision making
made a political choice that
was nothing short of brave,
right and fair, and that's courage.
But this whole issue of
the Confederate monuments
well he had to do his soul searching,
and he had to think through this,
and it was fraught with
personal and political risk.
But he did what was not popular,
and some may consider impolitic,
but it was right, he understood history.
He understands politics.
He understand the culture of his people,
and he did the courageous
thing, so I'm just pleased.